why do I feel like I look like a mime
doing walk of shame
hi guys my name is very telling if you
don't know now you know you're like it's
different now last Friday I start
commenting on your comments again I
thought that might be a cool thing to do
every Friday until I get bored with it
or I forget that's the thing that I've
established with you guys today I'm
going to comment on your comment I do
enjoy doing this but they also hope that
this inspires you to comment more
frequently or just comment at all on any
of my social media platform I'm at grace
Helbig across all social media platforms
so you have no excuse unless you just
don't like me and you don't want to
engage with me totally get it
I don't follow our president on Twitter
polarizing comment let's start over
entire city calmly place that utilizes
140 characters that isn't the inside of
my brain mecha blue coat new prisons
like new bring the ball vision do not
know when a new president columns on a
my social media platforms like great the
crap out of them are welcome to the
fifth grade family is to hasten oh it
great because why be mean when you can
be done if we just get it longer and
longer how do I know if it's a new
person I don't know I just get a K
everyone is a new person mecha blue go
more like omega flu yo I'm blue dabu
devolve of diverse that would be double
jeopardy dad who died yeah has anyone
ever checked in on that singer to see if
they were actually having a stroke in
that moment and that we just turned it
into some like modern version of
scatting new burglary
it's driving me crazy so I have to ask
even if you'll never answer why is goose
always wearing a shirt it's a very
scientific reason for this maybe you've
heard of the Thunder shirt or weighted
blankets people or animals with anxiety
love being swaddled in things which has
nothing to do with the fact that
aesthetically I just love when she wears
clothes also she has a huge amount of
anxiety real DC Newport super super and
real DC more like fake Marvel comic
books nope stay in your lane Helbig stay
in your lane super grood either great
pelvic is the cutest once you think she
looks like a Hanson or I'm attracted to
the Hanson yeah this is a tough one
because the more I look at myself as an
adult the more I think I'm morphing into
a member of Hanson I've met
in this on snapchat which I don't think
it's a bad thing by the way I mean
talking about having a stroke while
singing mmm this is deaf and dumb do
that's it which member of Hanson do you
think I look most like leave a comment
down below
Bailey tone it you preservation person
Bailey tone it more like Bailey toilet
can you function and also the occasional
my phone when I drop it into the toilet
before a business meeting which I
tweeted out the other day which actually
happened I don't want to tell you
whether I'd already systematize do you
agree I found a new obsession with grace
Helbig Oh Bailey you tweet like you are
transcribing a UK one commercial and I
don't hate it
hey lumpy a senpai super super
depressing Taylor PSN say more like
Kayla pitches and towards data info she
she's a data processor and she turned
her desk chair up in her cubicle
twerking to a toilet so she's just
teasing and data Oh Kayla you can group
can't believe breath oh my god I'm not
scottysire shout out rap over me pretty
pissed TBH if you don't know scottysire
and all those guys to check the mounds
they're going to be on upcoming episodes
of my podcast is really exciting and
when they came into my podcast I asked
Gotti to do a rap shout out for me at
the end of his video because that's what
he does at the end of his videos and it
took him a month but he finally did it
and I'll link the video below for you to
go check it out because it is like I
want to say I felt like I was watching
Eminem but I wasn't watching mmm it's
like it was like a mounds bar which
people really love thank you got it now
good Graham I don't know how to feel
through things and I don't have a theme
on Instagram I just like to give fact
sometimes potato a new president person
person potato age more like I also love
to help potatoes because their purpose
in life as food is to be eaten and so
that's my version of giving a charity is
eating french fries your group give me
your face no veto my face
I don't hate it and it can do really
great impressions of such celebrities as
Robert De Niro or even like a Craigslist
impersonator of Robert De Niro nefarious
with Nana Farkas Nebojsa snow Farkas
Nebojsa
nipple is a stroke of the food nefarious
nefarious nefarious you person-to-person
person afar is more like miss get a new
username please dear God never grows I
thought you were Titanic Sinclair at
first WTF who is Titanic Sinclair's is
where we learned together tetanic
Sinclair's a director writer living in
LA and this is what they look like
ok I can see the correlation people
and/or myself have thought I look like
Michael Jackson a member of violence and
Taekwondo Flair way to make a girl feel
special Internet Rebecca menchaca
Cooper's new birth new furs and Rebecca
Montano more like this username looks
like you were trying to type the
username Reba McEntire but like all of
your fingers kind of fell off through
that process so you ended up with
Rebecca menchaca you look great great I
really like that you are so great thank
you for doing that my life is different
now compared to before
cringe face emoticon is that a twenty
one pilots no go to get really yours
here right now Maggie Allen your person
to person to person Maggie Allen more
like Maggie Allen wrench that's a tool
you're a tool different groups
don't worry as kids can talk pretty well
it to and twins can usually communicate
with each other before that it's not
witchcraft
that's not witchcraft definition
nightmare I mean children are gift and
your love new person super kindergarten
Andrew Lowe more like Andrew hi where
have you been well having that commented
on your car before when can we hang out
make a video together new group oh my
god to that I say you I Jesus
Camille has new person first new person
come
hats more like Camille has a lot of time
to write comments on my video and a lot
of classes yoga group so Bobby Carozza
mentioned in 1899 by Luis Marcus he died
at the age of 102 so because I read my
comic and I now call this video
entertainment and not be deleted in the
restricted mode on YouTube Mishawaka
post Newport News person to person
Mishawaka post more like I miss awawa
post those me verbally sending a tweet
out about how much I miss Wawa the
comedian stories that are only in a very
small section of the mid-atlantic region
on the east coast of the United States
they're great stores or named after the
found that a goose makes not my dog an
actual animal goose wah-wah you're the
good beer is brewed to be savored and my
parents hoped I wouldn't be an idiot as
an adult but not all things turn out the
way that you brew them okay that's it
for commenting on your comments this
week I hope you guys enjoyed this video
if you did don't forget to like the
video and subscribe to this YouTube
channel and click a little bill icon to
get notifications of when I upload
videos because this inconsistent and
sporadic to save the most and make sure
you follow me on all social media
platforms like I said at grace Helbig
across the board I'll see you guys at
some point in the mirror to distant
future
idols oh oh warmest drop out new person
person to person I wanna shop out more
like I wanna Lemon Drop martini
outside right now personal [ __ ] you've
been great I'm so glad you're showing
off goose now I'm glad you're glad
because if you're going to be a digital
media influencer there's no reason to
have an animal unless you're going to
exploit them for popularity or financial
stability if you're getting an animal
for love get over yourself
you can't cash that check at the bank